[Musique]
oui
à bienvenue sur tv 78 nouvelle édition
du 7 8 politique voici le sommaire de ce
mois de juin après les européennes cap
sur les municipales le scrutin se
déroulera en 2020 le parti présidentiel
vient d'installer sa commission
nationale d'investitures quelles
ambitions pour les marcheurs invité
pierre lui ce référent local de la
république en marche avant même
d'envisager les municipales du côté des
républicains se pose déjà la question de
la reconstruction départ de laurent
wauquiez initiative de reconquête par
les territoires de gérard larcher et
départ de valérie pécresse les derniers
jours ont été agités philippe benassaya
maire de bois d'arcy conseiller
départemental est aussi vice président
les républicains dans les yvelines en
charge de l'information de la
communication
il est en plateau bonjour philippe
benassaya jo est bienvenue pour le 7-8
politique nous allons revenir sur la
situation de votre famille politique
justement et après le départ de valérie
pécresse il ya eu aussi l appel des
maires 70 mère qui ont signé une texte
dans lequel ils appellent à la réussite
du gouvernement comment vous avez
accueilli ce texte lorsque vous l'avez
découvert coûté sait les conséquences de
notre résultat aux présidentielles de
2017 et aux résultats des européennes
nous ne sommes pas à la hauteur du socle
de droite cas dans ce pays c'est à dire
que le party les républicains et en
dessous très probablement de l'étiage
électorale de la droite dans ce pays
voilà donc ça c'est déjà un premier
point et c'est vraiment très regrettable
pourquoi d'abord parce que je pense
qu'il ya un vrai problème générationnel
dans ce parti je les dis en toute
franchise nous avons pas perdu deux
grands leaders et nous n'avons pas fait
ce travail de renouvellement que
d'autres partis d'autres familles
politiques ont fait et deuxièmement je
pense qu'il ya un problème de ligne
politique de clarté politique dont moi
même je ne sais même pas si vous me
posiez la question si vous posez la
question je ne saurais même pas vous
définir la politique des républicains
donc on est dans la nasse ça arrive
c'est la politique
un jour on est en haut un jour on est en
bas ça arrivera à d'autres parce que la
politique c'est un c'est un jeu de
mouvement perpétuel
aujourd'hui ça tombe sur notre parti
politique on n'est pas habitué à cela
parce que la droite a toujours eu les
républicains n'ont jamais été aussi
basses n'a jamais été aussi bas
voilà exactement on n'a jamais été aussi
bas et en plus la droite a plutôt fait
de très bons scores même quand elles
perdent au deuxième tour à une élection
mais général on arrive toujours à 40 45
47 48 on n'a pas du tout l'habitude de
ce résultat là donc il faut en tirer les
conséquences
rester dans cette famille politique là
pour pouvoir reconstruire saiem phrase
de léon blum n'est pas deux mondes deux
mots courants politiques mais qui est un
très grand homme d'état qui disait
pendant que vous irez courir laventure
il va bien falloir quelqu'un pour garder
la vieille maison
donc voilà je là je fais mienne cette
cette citation on a vu passer les
résultats aux européennes pendant que
vous répondiez résultats aux européennes
dans le département des yvelines où les
républicains sont en baisse partout on
voit les les différents scores
malgré la présence de françois xavier
bellamy en tête de liste qui
représentait en quelque sorte versailles
qui est conseiller municipal à
versailles ça vous a surpris ce score
alors regardez bien regardez bien ce
tableau d'abord il ya une participation
qui est à 50% qui est plutôt pas mal
pour pour des organes par rapport à
carros et nous mais c'est 50% de
d'électeurs qui se déplacent c'est à
dire une personne sur deux sur les
inscrits ce qui n'est pas beaucoup
et ensuite
le deuxième point c'est que les
résultats sont pas terrible pour tout le
monde a envie de dire d'abord pour nous
ça c'est déjà un problème réglé on en a
parlé il ya quelques minutes
je pense que c'est pas beau un bon
résultat pour la gauche non plus et pas
mon résultat pour en marche non plus
parce que on voit qu'ils ont perdu des
voix par rapport aux présidentielles
même s'il faut pas confondre d'élections
donc moi ce que je dis c'est que les
européennes c'est toujours une élection
un petit peu hors sol c'est une élection
à paron parti écologiste en général est
un peu plus haut que d'habitude parce
que la sensibilité écologique ce est
plus sensible au niveau européen qu'au
niveau municipal local
je pense qu'il faut revenir à des
élections plus traditionnels j'ai envie
de dire pour voir où en est les familles
politiques françaises aujourd'hui encore
faut-il des candidats alors ce que vous
avez vu le départ aussi de valérie
pécresse est ce que vous vous êtes dit
bon peut-être moi aussi je pourrais
quitter les républicains quand vous irez
courir laventure il va bien falloir
critères pour garder la vieille maison
que je répète la citation nomblot non je
plaisante mais je je je pense que le
sujet principal c'est la rencontre la
reconstruction de cette famille
politique très importante avec des
droites dans ce parti il faut pas
oublier qu'on a toujours parlé de gauche
plurielle pendant des années mini une
droite plurielle s'il ya une droite
libérale et une droite conservatrice une
droite souverainiste une droite
catholique une droite laïque sociale
gaulliste voyez il ya beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de familles et aujourd'hui
force est de constater des républicains
la famille le parti politique et
républicains ne rassemble pas tous ses
cours il va bien falloir faire ce
travail mais je pense que valérie
pécresse même si elle a eu 7 7 de cette
décision de partir je pense qu'elle fera
aux cibles montre de reconstruction dans
les années à venir je pense qu'ils vont
exclure personne en ce qui vous concerne
vous restez aux républicains oui cette
ancienne famille politique ma famille
même si la situation est difficile avec
18 dans les familles mais on se
réconcilie après au sein du département
des yvelines il faut aussi aussi
reconstruire néanmoins est ce que vous
pensez qu'un renouvellement des
changements seraient seraient
nécessaires à quelques-uns des
structures départementales faire rentrer
des nouveaux visages ozil est de 878
excusez moi je pense à une passe du
conseil départemental
oui je pense que ce qui se passe alors
il faut être
il faut être aussi un petit peu honnête
c'est que nous nous avons récupéré pas
mal de militants avec bellamy et les
européennes
il faut savoir que nous sommes un peu en
hausse par rapport à ce qu'on était
avant les européennes et après la
présidentielle
je me console comme je peux mais c'est
vrai que c'est un bon départ pourquoi
parce qu'on refait du terrain on refait
la politique
on va voir les gens on essaie de
construire un socle programmatique que
dans le 78 nous a pas forcément réussi
au niveau des résultats mais je pense
que même si saxby bellamy a fait une
belle campagne
je pense qu'on est en reconstruction un
peu au niveau local comme au niveau
national il faut laisser le temps au
temps encore une fois je suis une
citation mais c'est vrai qu'il faut il
faut laisser le temps au temps et
laisser cette grande famille politique
du gaullisme au libéralisme se
reconstruire et c'est pour ça que moi je
veux participer à cette aventure alors
quand ça à l'extérieur du parti comme
comme valérie pécresse ou les mères qui
ont signé le manifeste 603 dans les
histoires je doive pardon de saint
pierre de saint germain en laye en a
l'air de pau est sincère de montblanc
voilà c'est ça et je pense que chacun de
son côté a envie de reconstruire la
droite dans ce pays qu'on soit à
l'intérieur du parti
on conçoit l'extérieur on a tous j'ai
l'impression que quand on se réveille le
matin coups soit dans le parti websphere
du parti on a tous envie de reconstruire
la droite en france aujourd'hui il faut
vraiment repartir des territoires comme
le souhait de gérard larcher
très bonne initiative for partir des
territoires je pense que nous allons
arriver à d'autres échéances politiques
vous allez peut-être en parler je sais
pas vous mais au municipal et
municipales c'est autre chose
l'étiquette politique ne joue pas ou
très peu
moi j'ai été élu en 2000 en 2014 avec
une étiquette politique
alors qu'on m'avait prédit médias comme
comme institut sondage que j'allais
perdre c'est ça dépend de l'équation
personnelle delà de la personne
justement et les municipales c'est fait
pour rassembler rassembler sur des
projets rassembler sur des talents
rassembler sur des compétences moi j'ai
une équipe municipale par exemple où il
ya des élèves des gens divers droite et
divers gauche des associatifs des gens
qui ont envie de travailler à l'avenir
de bois d'arcy
donc il faut raison garder d'abord à mon
avis on reconstruit au niveau national
la famille politique et ensuite faire
cap reçus en faire cap sur les
municipales avec des majorités de projet
de progrès de rassemblement
néanmoins dans un temps très court les
municipales ce sera pour 2020 et début
2000 20 vous parlez des différentes
tendances au sein de votre liste déjà
première question est ce que vous serez
candidat vous en 2020 très probablement
je serai candidat très probable on sait
juste pour faire durer un peu le
suspense mais je serai candidat en 2020
on a commencé des projets il faut
définir ses projets six ans et
qu'aujourd'hui maintenant dans le tempo
politique d'aujourd'hui c'est très très
peu mon prédécesseur a été élu sur trois
mandats voilà il faut du temps pour
réaliser cela jean train de refaire un
gymnase une école l'avenue principale de
bois d'arcy
nous n'avons pas terminer j'aimerais
qu'on fasse qu'on continue à faire cap
sur le cadre de vie puisque c'est notre
projet principal environnement et puis
sur la sécurité et sur sur le numérique
bon ça j'ai pas terminée et il faut
moderniser encore cette ville et donc
vous serez candidat et vous parliez des
différents stands en différents bilans
dans ce pardon sur votre liste ça veut
dire peut-être aussi des républiques en
marche sur votre liste
ce scrutin vous savez les des étiquettes
ça fait évident qu'en 2020 les
étiquettes entièrement privé et
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation un
peu inédite
il faut pas prendre des gens parce
qu'ils ont une étiquette politique je
sais dire que lorsque la négociation des
municipales arrivera je vais pas prendre
pour nous n'allons pas discuter avec des
remarques justement parce qu'ils sont en
marche il parce qu ils sont l air parce
qu ils sont parti radical ou divers
gauche etc
je prendrai des personnes des arcisien
qui voudront adhérer un projet moi je
fais mienne également la phrase de karl
olive qui l'a dit il ya quelques jours
quand on se lève le matin on n'est pas
là pour faire un projet de gauche ou un
projet de droite
moi je fais une école en ce moment mon
école elle n'est pas de droite ou de
gauche elle répond aux critères d
arcisien je voudrais vraiment faire ce
que j'ai fait en 2014 je voudrais leur
faire en 2020 c'est à dire ouvrir cette
liste va faire 10 politique mes
prédécesseurs ont fait des listes
vraiment très politique ancrée à gauche
- 2014 est ouvert ça au monde associatif
à la droite au centre gauche j'ai
utilisé du centre gauche on parle
souvent politiques en dehors du conseil
municipal ça c'est assez marrant
d'ailleurs mais mais parce qu'ils
avaient un projet selon me voir en
disant moi je voudrais travailler là
dessus et j'ai fait travailler là dessus
la municipale c'est le moment important
de la vie républicaine et ça c'est au
moment des élections parce qu'on sait
après au delà des municipales se joue
aussi les intercommunalités et on
demandé
communalité la fracture gauche-droite la
retrouve plus ou moins tout de même il
faut faire une majorité il faut faire
une majorité mais c'est assez c'est
assez léger parce qu'il ya souvent des
consensus dans les agglomérations
ici ou ailleurs il ya souvent des
consensus qui se joue au delà des partis
politiques je pense qu'il faut vraiment
que l'on fasse abstraction médias comme
politique on fasse abstraction sur le
fait que les municipales c'est un
référendum politique ou c'est un enjeu
de politique nationale ça n'a jamais été
le cas c'est vrai qu'on est sous le choc
des européennes
doudou les d'où les questions mais
vraiment canton constitue je vous assure
un canton constitue une équipe
municipale
on ne pense pas l'étiquette politique
qu'on pense à la personne qu'on a vu par
exemple lors d'une manifestation et dont
on dit tiens pas mal celui là il
pourrait peut-être s'occuper de x ou y
ou z ça serait bien il a il parle bien
il a eu un projet dans son quartier je
trouve que c'est plutôt une bonne idée
qu'il a eue on va le voir on discute
avec lui il est d'accord n'est pas
d'accord c'est autre chose
je vais pas voir cette personne en me
disant qu'elle est votre étiquette
politique ce serait ridicule de ma part
et je n'ai jamais fait quoi
l'officialisation de votre candidature
et de votre liste ce sera pour quand
pour la rentrée on sait rien je veux
faire un petit séminaire d'élus bientôt
dans le mois pour voir un petit peu
comment on s'organise très probable on a
commencé à bouger à l'automne mais je
n'ai pas encore de de timing de
calendrier politique
merci philippe benassaya est revenu en
plateau maire de bois d'arcy
vice-président également des
républicains dans les yvelines merci à
vous merci
les formations politiques en pleine
préparation pour les élections
municipales elles se tiendront en 2020 a
priori en mars
autant dire qu'en coulisses les
directions elle s'affaire pour désigner
les têtes de liste l analyse des
résultats des européennes tient
forcément une place importante notamment
pour la république en marche qui a évité
un effondrement pourtant annoncé un
temps après la crise ld gilet jaune
pierre l'ush bonjour et bienvenue en
plateau référent lrm dans les yvelines
tout d'abord ce score aux européennes
vous a rassuré sur l'ancrage de votre
formation sur le département longtemps
c'est toujours rassurant de faire un bon
score
il est évident que dans les yvelines on
réalise une avancée par rapport aux
autres partis donc oui on est très
satisfait de ce score localement pour la
première fois votre formation va se
présenter aux élections municipales ce
sera le cas aussi pour la france
insoumis génération aussi le paysage
politique a été fortement bousculée
depuis l élection à des manuels macron
ça veut dire qu'il faut faire table rase
du passé aussi pour ces élections
municipales et éviter le clivage gauche
droite nous a dit qu'en marchant
proposera donc le cas
un programme un projet pour l'ensemble
des villes les yvelines qui ne sera pas
du tout inscrit dans ce clivage
ancestrale puisque on présentera des
progrès de progrès des progrès
écologique des progrès aussi de
démocratie locale
on se cherche même pas du tout à se
situer dans dance est dans cet archétype
politique de la gauche ou la droite
comme comme on l'a fait pour les
présidentielles police hâtives et pour
les européennes on va y revenir plus en
détail mais tout d'abord le comité d
investiture qui vient d'être relancée
par la république est en marche
ça va se passer comment sur le terrain
il ya des discussions d'abord ici en
local ensuite au national qu'elle est un
peu le timing prévu pour les villes les
plus importantes c'est une décision qui
sera prise au niveau national mais avec
la vie évidemment du comité politique du
département des animateurs locaux des
adhérents qui sont les personnes qui
connaissent mieux le terrain et les
forces politiques en place et les
opportunités qui peuvent se présenter
pour dans les yvelines ya déjà des noms
de candidats n'ont pas là que vous
n'avez pas de décider des têtes
d'affiché aussi peut-être les
instituteurs seront établis à partir du
moins une fois la commission nationale
vient de commencer son travail ses
talons à partir du mois de juin au mois
d'octobre
donc pour l'instant il n'y a pas de nom
qui a été qu'il était décédé le 16 qui
est difficile aussi c'est dans ces
élections municipales c'est surtout
d'avoir cet ancrage local cette
légitimité au sein d'une commune
vis-à-vis des électeurs plus que jamais
les électeurs ont besoin de cette
proximité là c'est à dire que sur le
terrain vous allez rencontrer
d'éventuels candidats qui étaient sous
une autre étiquette par le passé ou
peut-être des maires qui sont déjà en
place qui ont été élus sur certaines
étiquettes pour qu'il vous rejoignent
alors vous savez la clique à marca
mouvements récents mais les militants
qui la composent ne sont pas tous
arrivés sur leur territoire
il ya deux semaines certains sont
présents depuis longtemps ont des gars
cet ancrage et
si l'étiquette avec lui quand marc elle
est nouvelle les candidats leur
connaissance du territoire
elle n'est pas nouvelle donc on a toute
la légitimité possible pour présenter
les grands qui connaissent leur ville
qui ont des projets cohérents pour leur
télé je vais vous citer tout de même un
nom vous ne vouliez pas me donner de
nous encore rien n'était arrêté mais
celui de rares berger par exemple qui
était une qui est aujourd'hui la porte
parole à l'assemblée nationale de votre
mouvement
ancienne candidate des républicains lors
des précédentes législatives qui
maintenant est élu du côté de
rambouillet en tant que députée elle
pourrait être candidate à la mairie de
rambouillet par exemple lieu ça serait
probablement de lui demander si elle est
candidate à l'investiture mais ça sera
dans tous les cas elle comme ils sont
l'assemblée d'investiture qui quittera
qu'en qui sera dé 6,2 a su néanmoins
sans donner de nom un nombre important
de mer ont d'ores et déjà annoncé qu'il
ne souhaitait pas se représenter devant
la difficulté de la tâche et puis aussi
la par rapport à leur fonction qui sont
aujourd'hui moindre devant le poids
grandissant des agglomérations
ça veut dire que vous allez avoir du mal
aussi à trouver ses candidats c'est la
fonction de maire est particulièrement
difficile parfois assez ingrate
donc effectivement trouver des personnes
compétentes qui ont envie et qui sont
conscientes des défis que ça représente
c'est pas forcément facile mais c'est
aussi la preuve que tous les cons et là
qu on sélectionnera seront des gens qui
auront le bon profil et qui défendront
les bons projets il ya des candidats qui
vous sollicitent déjà bien sûr j'ai
plein d'amis depuis les élections
européennes mais c'est pas la
sollicitation qui fait le larron
c'est le projet qu'il porte dans le
viseur certaines communes j'imagine
emblématique du département est ce qu'il
y aura des candidats dans toutes les
communes qui auront cette étiquette la
république en marche nous excusons
seulement dans ça ce sera le cas dans
seulement certaines communes ou alors
est-ce qu'il n'y aura pas d'étiquette
aussi peut-être tout simplement on
n'impose pas vous savez sur le sol des
élections municipales le port d'une
étiquette est pas toujours indispensable
pas toujours pertinents une liste
municipale est souvent composée de gens
qui viennent de plusieurs courants
politiques qui n'ont pas forcément envie
de se voir attribuer une étiquette d'un
parti ça sera très variable en fonction
des communes il est comme une houe
on sera en mesure de porter un
rassemblement très large et est ce qui
est toujours favorable moi je suis très
favorable à ce qu'on puisse créer des
rassemblements si on porte pas
d'étiquette c'est pas grave si on
rassemble le maximum de personnes
derrière un projet qui qui sont
favorables
il ya plusieurs élus candidats
potentiels qui pourraient venir de
l'arrêt de des républicains aussi tout
simplement on l'a vu il ya eu pas mal de
départs et puis à cet appel du pied qui
a été fait aussi par la république en
marchant vers l'est républicain est ce
que c'est le cas quels sont les liens
avec les républicains dans le
département aujourd'hui l'appui comment
je serai fidèle à ses valeurs c'est à
dire que l'on sera ouvert on écrira
toujours les personnes porteuses de
progrès qui adhéreront à nos valeurs et
mais on sera toujours aussi exigeant
envers elle c'est à dire que c'est pas
un moulin lequel on entrerait la
réplique en marche facilement non c'est
par contre on accueillera toutes les
personnes qui ont à la fois le bon
profil qui porte les bonnes valeurs et
qui sont en mesure de rassembler
défendre un projet aura tout de même un
équilibre gauche droite pour ne pas trop
penché vers la droite justement garder
cet équilibre
alors ça c'est pour se replacer
systématiquement dans ce clivage gauche
droite c'est pas
france sas transcrit forcément dans la
qualité des projets qu'on présente donc
on fera entre attentif à sa lo green
politique très sincèrement sera pas un
critère de choix pour revenir sur cette
campagne est la façon dont elle va se
dérouler les tickets ne sera pas mise en
avant
ça c'est pas le but nous notre but c'est
de présenter des projets qui permettent
de diffuser nos valeurs dans chacune des
villes les yvelines et d'améliorer les
conditions de vie des gens dans leur
quotidien
il aura un programme commun déjà pour
ses différentes communes il y aura des
éléments pro le mans en commun nous on
met l'accent sur le plan intercommunal
puisque clopine de compétences
importantes dans la vie quotidienne se
font au niveau des communautés de
communes communautés d'agglomération et
donc effectivement certaines villes
auront en commun des éléments
programmatiques qui seront travaillés
ensemble par les futures listes pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de mer de la
république en marche donc département
des yvelines pourtant il ya eu des
élections anticipées
récemment c'était à saint rémy les
chevreuse battu de 22 voix par une liste
sans étiquette justement le candidat de
la république en en marche
ça démontre que l étiquette sera pas
forcément le meilleur des atouts alors
on a un maire l'apico marqué ses fans
mirambeau avis le bruit qui court
effectivement vous mettez françois que
l'étiquette soit soit le flot des plus
importantes surtout dans les petites
villes ou
où la personnalité des candidats et les
projets qui portent son nom risque qui
retient le plus l'attention des citoyens
le déroulement de cette campagne les
investisseurs et restitue re qui vont se
dérouler à partir du mois de juin nous
disait tout à l'heure
ensuite sur le terrain à partir de quand
on n'a jamais quitté le terrain on y est
depuis 2010 est et les personnes qui
sont kiki qui ont dès qu'ils ont envie
de s'investir mais la vie municipale
ils sont encore on a des consultations
locales lancé dans un certain nombre de
villes il ya qui ont déjà eu lieu on
parlait de montesson de conflans de
gouye ya déjà des dé travail de terrain
qui est fait pour justement recueillir
les avis intérêts de la population est
ce qu'ils ont envie de faire ce qu'ils
ont envie de voir venir dans leur ville
merci pierre plus d'être venus
participer à ce 7,8 politique je
rappelle que vous êtes le référent de la
république en marchant sur le
département
avant de refermer ce numéro un point sur
les candidatures déclarées aux
prochaines municipales tout d'abord à
guyancourt où rodolphe barry 58 ans se
lance dans la campagne avec une liste
sans étiquette il était adjoint du maire
de voisins-le-bretonneux jusqu'en 2014
il se présentera face à françois un
morton divers gauche tout juste élu par
la majorité après la démission de marie
christine le tarnec
et il compte conserver son poste dans
quelques mois même situation à saint cyr
l'école avec sonia bros également à
coignières avec le divers gauche est
didier fischer ils ont hérité du poste
de premier édile en cours de mandat et
le demanderont donc aux électeurs de la
conforter en 2027 place et puis
plusieurs maires sortants auteur d'un ou
plusieurs mandats ont fait le choix
d'annoncer dès à présent leur
candidature jean michel fourgous élu
républicain est en cours ou encore guy
malandain que vous voyez à l'image élus
et divers gauche attrape guy malandain
qui sera notamment face au conseiller
régional proche de valérie pécresse
othman nasri et qui a annoncé sa
candidature fin de 7,8 politique pour ce
mois de juin
on se retrouve en juillet d'ici là
l'actualité politique est à suivre au
quotidien dans le journal
[Musique]